a senior Diplomat from Zimbabwe has
agreed to launder more than a billion
dollars in cash in what he believed to
be a meeting with Chinese gangsters also
as investigative unit has found a
diplomat was videotaped making the offer
in a meeting with undercover reporters
as part of an investigation by Al
Jazeera into networks in Africa that use
gold to launder vast sums of money
Uber Angel is a British Zimbabwean
businessman and the presidential Envoy
he claims to have made it to the Africa
Forbes rich list in 2013. his net worth
is around 60 million dollars and he
calls himself the profit of success
Alexander James has this exclusive
report
good to see you undercover reporters
posing as Chinese criminals meet one of
Zimbabwe's most senior diplomats
out of 85 countries but on this special
Envoy I'm a representative of the
president that means I can sign
contracts I can sign treaties with
government without the president getting
involved woman with a trip
Uber tangel is also an Evangelical
preacher
who says he has the gift of Prophecy
with powers to heal the sick it takes
the power of God but it takes somebody
to believe
for something to happen like this
Angel was personally appointed by
President Emerson manangagwa to bring
investment into Zimbabwe he is my first
Ambassador at large assigned
to promote Zimbabwe brand
Zimbabwe's economy has been devastated
by corruption and more than two decades
of sanctions imposed by the United
States and Europe
the local currency has no International
value the country's biggest earner of
U.S dollars is gold you want a gold gold
we can do it right now we can make the
call right now and it's done with the
president of um Association right this
minute
the president of Zimbabwe's miners
Federation is Henrietta rashware they
want to invest in Golden by gold and
maybe it's in the private jet pick picks
up gold every week
let's do it bro five million dollars can
be cleaned every week
[Music]
the Ambassador is not bothered that the
cash is being laundered it's money that
cannot be declared in the country of
orange
he explains a plan to smuggle the dirty
cash into Zimbabwe using his diplomatic
status
with 1.2 billion and put a red tape
written Diplomat that's it
under the Vienna convention States agree
to exempt diplomatic luggage from
airport searches it's a very very easy
until I get to my house
Ambassador Angel Henrietta rashware and
president manangagwa did not respond to
our request for comments Alexander James
Al Jazeera
and you can watch the first part of the
four-part series in the al-zera
investigation gold Mafia the laundry
service on Thursday at 20 GMT
hope Paul chenono is an anti-corruption
activist and documentary maker and he's
in Harare and now with us live good to
have you with us at the findings of this
investigation are shocking but do they
surprise you
thank you very much for hosting me the
findings are shocking to the outside
world but they are not shocking to
journalists or investigative journalists
like myself because we're always
reported about these things but what Al
Jazeera is done which we were not able
to do is to put the evidence and to have
the People speaking themselves about how
they are involved in the Looting of
public funds the plan of Zimbabwe's
natural resources the smuggling of these
resources and the laundering of money
using State institutions as they said in
the documentary film most journalists in
this country that have come across this
information are afraid to report about
it because they will be thrown into
prison I've been thrown into prison
myself three times and one of the
reasons that I was thrown into prison is
because Henrietta schwein who is the
President's niece and who has been
exposed in this documentary film by Al
Jazeera
um was also caught at Zimbabwe's Robert
Mugabe International Airport uh in
October of 2020 trying to smuggle 6.7
kilograms of gold to Dubai when she was
caught she was offered a a a bell deal
without where they instead of not
opposed barrel and when I exposed that I
was arrested thrown into prison for 25
days and and so a lot of journalists are
afraid to report on these issues uh
because they look at what has happened
to me and they are afraid of being
thrown into prison because nobody is
able to help them out but now that Al
Jazeera has put this information out
it's important uh for local journalists
to look at it and report on it because
it's not coming from them it's coming
from an international news network has
there been any response any official
response from people in Zimbabwe
well the government has not responded
officially but the ruling party has used
one of its uh Twitter handles to dismiss
the film uh on the basis that it does
not involve a government minister or it
does not involve a civil servant
um but the fact of the matter is Israel
said in its press release there are four
films so we are still waiting to see
what else comes but the fact that the
Ambassador at large was appointed by the
president of the Republic uh president
is involved not only in the smuggling of
gold or laundering of money but also
charging people to have access to the
president is Criminal so we are now
waiting to see whether the government is
going to prosecute these people but um
we are not hopeful based on what has
happened in the past okay well that's
interesting isn't it what does it do
though to the government's argument in
Zimbabwe that its economic woes of which
there are many are due to International
sanctions against the country
well this document
has uh destroyed that argument because
we can now see clearly that there are
huge amount of money that are being made
um one one of the uh people in the film
talked about making millions every week
uh Zimbabwe has got only six Central
hospitals and they require only 50 55
million US dollars to run efficiently
without any shortages for the whole year
so if somebody is able to make 20
million through smuggling of gold and is
that in taxes with with being aided by
state agents uh it means that we don't
have medication in our hospitals not
because of sanctions but because we've
got a group of criminals who are part of
a political cabal who are stealing from
the state and stealing from the citizens
and making sure that a lot of our people
die from easily treatable diseases like
you can cholera and Thai food when
things could have moved absolutely
Hopewell chinono great to speak to you
thanks very much for taking the time to
join us here on Al Jazeera